rough go he grew up rough
and um and he he changed things around
and and he gives back i mean the first
week he was in town he was out doing
community work i mean that's just how he
how he goes
um and then he's always here
i mean you it it's funny because we're
working in the stadium now
and so we have golf carts that circle
the stadium circle inside the stadium on
this
on the carpet we've got the great tires
you know i mean we've got it all
set up where we can drive these things
in one direction around the stadium and
utilize all the space we possibly can
for social distancing
so every day i drive by the part of the
defensive
uh meeting room and where the where the
defensive backs end up going after the
defense breaks up
and he's in there i go up early early he
is in there by himself and
he's talking to the to the film he's
looking at he's evaluating
evaluating the film and and he makes
funny noises i think that's why they
call him the badger
i mean you know he makes all these
little crunching groans as he's watching
so uh but he you know he
he is into it and he is so smart and
and such a uh he's smart on the field
and off the field
and such a good leader and he does it
with this great energy
and intimidated by nothing he just he
wants to challenge every play
[Music]
peter king's truncated training camp
tour this year due to the pandemic has
taken him
to among other places kansas city you
can read all about it in today's
football morning in america and here is
some of peter king
talking with the defending super bowl
mvp from the defending super bowl
champions patrick mahomes
about how he hopes to get even better in
2020 players work on things in the off
season and even after you've won a super
bowl i'm sure you
you know you say man i want to get
better at x
give me one or two things that you've
really
focused on this off season even if
they're little technical things
that you've really worked on to try to
get better as a football player
uh the biggest thing to me i think has
been trying to
diagnose defenses even quicker i think
that that's something that uh
i got a great challenge on these first
two years is uh the the
the only knock about having such a good
offense these first two years is we get
to see
several different defenses every single
year and we i mean every single game and
different defenses that we scout for
different defenses that teams have
played the entire year
and i'm trying to do my best job of
being able to diagnose that quickly and
being able to make the adjustments in
time
now if you look at games like the colts
last year whenever we we played them
early in the season they came out of the
defense they hadn't played
uh since that that regime had to have
been been a part of there
and so uh we we were kind of taking off
guard we scored low points and they
ended up beating us
and i want to be able to make those
adjustments quicker um and be able to
go out there and have success at a
faster pace and so
um that's stuff that i've been looking
at of trying to find different ways to
to
make adjustments on the sideline quicker
and uh hopefully that'll pay off and
we'll see whenever the games come
patrick mahomes with peter king and the
scary thought is chris the guy
is going to get better he's only played
31 regular season games
he will see more things he will process
more information
his brain will eventually become a
football super computer
and you put that with those abilities my
god
it's amazing and it's scary to think of
how good he's going to be
five six seven eight years from now no
it is because he's got you know the
proper work ethic
and mindset and everything too along
with the talent to where you go uh oh
i mean this guy just gets it just you
know between that answer right there
and yeah he's young he's still learning
you know little tricks of the trade how
teams are playing them you know to his
point
defenses are going to do stuff against
the kansas city chiefs that you know
they're not going to do against a lot of
teams in football they're going
defense are going to buy kansas city
sometimes and go whoa
we can't play ours normal scheme against
this group he'll throw for 700 yards in
the first half of the game
we're gonna have to change up our
approach so he gets a lot of curveballs
because of that and the talent of their
team and
when that mental aspect of him goes to
the next level and they can trust him to
change
plays or he sees a route that should be
changed because the coverage is going to
be played a different way
uh you know great scots batman he'll be
unstoppable because he's almost
unstoppable already
starting with patrick mahomes let's do
some pft props on this monday morning
let's begin with his passing yards
for 2020. over under 4499.5
that's an average of 281 per game four
four nine nine point
five what do you got over 281 per game
that's easy no problemo for patrick
mahomes
okay i'm going over i am you know
i mean no otas last time we saw
like you know no off season the defenses
let up a lot of passing yards and i just
think between kansas city coming off the
super bowl and them feeling confident
and the pressure being off and defenses
probably being in a beginner phase here
early on in the season
i think he's going to put up some scary
numbers this year andy reid's got a
reputation for not running the ball
maybe as much as he could or
should well the presence of clyde
edwards hilaire rookie first round
running back and
brett veach the team's gm told peter
king that they expect a heavy workload
for edward solaire this year could that
maybe knock the numbers down a little
bit for my homes uh
i don't think it will i don't think it
will because i think
ultimately they're going to use edward
zelaire more still in the past game than
they will in the run game
they'd be crazy to go too much run game
right i mean to me that would just be
why the hell you paying tyree kill and
kelsey and mahomes all this money if
you're going to do that
your bread and butters throw the ball
put teams to put pressure on them that
way
and then they want to drop deep in these
deep zones oh here you go clyde edwards
hilaire here's a five yard
you know pass and make a linebacker look
silly in space and all of a sudden it
becomes a 30-yard gain
but if the defense has decided to do
everything they can to take away the
pass you got to be ready to run yeah you
do
become super bowl 36 and you're the rams
and you're blowing your opportunity just
run the ball down the patriots throats
all right
over under past touchdowns for patrick
mahomes this year 35.5 he had 50 in 2018
only 26 last year in part because he was
injured what do you got yeah i'm 35 and
a half i'm still going over here i'm i'm
expecting huge
offensive numbers from the kansas city
chiefs this year because of edward
hillaire
you know hope it sounds like you know
sammy watkins he's going to be good to
go here
michael hardman being in year two you
know yeah i'm
i'm expecting huge numbers i'm going
over all the way
all right here's one that i will i will
bet that you will take the over
i'm taking the over on you taking the
over on this one
aaron rodgers who seems to be poised to
embark on a middle finger to everyone
especially to those in the organization
you have some hard time
coming up with your words there yeah
yeah i want to be careful because even
though we're on peacock we still have to
watch what we say
he did throw a 60 yard touchdown pass in
practice yesterday he made a gesture
that i don't know that i can properly
explain either on peacock nbcs enter sky
sports you want me to do it safe
no no i don't either way either way
there are signs of a fire that is raging
in aaron rodgers over under past
touchdowns 25 and a half what do you
have oh
over baby oh aaron rodgers he's gonna be
so
freaking pissed this year i mean
yeah i'm going over you know and two to
one of our producers point pete
demelitis
you know he said it perfectly in a text
over this weekend he said
i got a feeling every time they're on
the two-yard line and got a run play
called the aj dillian or aaron jones
this year
he's gonna look over the sidelines and
say yeah eat it i'm throwing a touchdown
pass right here
eat that nice run play call but i'm
changing it i just think it's gonna be
one of those years and he's motivated
and i'm going over all the way
he had 25 in 2018 26 last year i agree
with you he's going to be over
my only question is who's he going to be
throwing him to because they didn't do
anything to really beef up the receiver
position but that won't matter he'll
throw him to himself
if he has to to get over 25 and a half
this year
all right in that same division the nfc
north chicago bears entering year three
with khalil mack remember they did that
trade right at labor day weekend to get
him from the raiders
mack was great in 2018 not as good in
2019 here he is talking about where he
currently stands in his career
i was good enough it wasn't good enough
at all and so
understanding that the different
intangibles that came with it
i don't make any excuses i uh just rise
to the occasion
and i'm getting ready for this one it's
gonna be a fun one man
i can't wait reminds me of a nick
riviera poem from the simpsons if it
isn't my old friend mr mcgregor with an
arm for a leg for an arm and an arm for
a leg i knew i'd get that out eventually
he has a leg for an arm chris
you can't wear that shirt on a day that
we show that clip of that guy's bicep
no he is well he's he's one of those
guys when he walks in the room
you go oh now i understand why you're
khalil mack
because he's all arms and neck and
hamstring and butt and quad and
you understand why he can throw around
315 pound offensive tackles when he's
258 pounds he's he's unbelievably
built that way i i mean i would expect
uh khalil mack to be motivated and
pissed off this year the stack's
over under over i'm going over all the
way 10 and a half seconds i'm going to
give you the number i'm going over there
yeah i'm going over it though because
between akeem hicks being back and
healthy and then robert quinn on the
other side
and then i just think khalil mack has a
standard he's going to hold himself to
he's going to be pissed off and ready to
go this year i'm going over all the way
akeem hicks is an underrated force on
that no doubt and without him it's a
different operation altogether and you
know it's a testament to the guys who
just grind
and grind and grind and the average fan
just kind of shrugs but
that's one of the big reasons why mac
was so good in 2018 because hicks was
healthy and there no doubt the whole
year all right
alvin kamara saints running back he's
looking for more highlight reel plays
over under
on yards from scrimmage 15 24.5
is the number he had 1500 plus his first
two seasons 13 30 last year when he was
dealing with a knee injury most of the
season 15 24.5 chris over under yeah i
mean i
i hate to be like johnny over during
this segment but i'm going over here
again
contract year you know michael thomas
jared cook emanuel sanders there you got
to worry about them a motivated camara
and a drew brees who knows how good
camara is and sean payton too so yeah i
think he goes off this year
statistically
this is where it becomes a little
fascinating and you get into that nuance
of a guy in a contract
year if you're sean payton i know does
that
creep into your game planning at all
chris and cause you to not dial up as
many plays
so you don't showcase the guy who's
going to go out and have 2 000 yards
from scrimmage
and now you're not going to be able to
afford him i i do think it will go into
their thought process
yes whether they want to or not on a
human level they're not going to want to
but
business-wise i was on a team once where
we had a receiver about to
get the big money at the end of the
season right he needed like a few more
catches
the team wanted to hold him out hey
you're good we'll hold you out he's like
no
i can need the catches for 250 000 thank
you
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports